estamos trabajando juntos con respeto
mutuo
y un aprecio Genuino el uno por el otro
para avanzar
en un futuro más próspero y más seguro
para nuestro pueblo la razón de esta
cumbre de esta relación trilateral
la razón por la cual es tan importante
es porque compartimos una visión común
para el futuro
y valores comunes y hablo de esto
sinceramente son valores comunes los que
compartimos nuestros países desde
convertirlo al presidente me he enfocado
en la reconstrucción de la economía
estadounidense
desde el fondo y desde la mitad no
no queremos jugar con nuestra economía y
esto funciona Porque los adinerados
reciben dinero y el resto de personas
también reciben dinero a todo el mundo
le va bien desde abajo significa
invertir en prioridades para las
familias trabajadoras los Estados Unidos
han hecho una inversión histórica y
partidista en infraestructura y en
Innovación que ya empezó a entregar
resultados concretos el pueblo
estadounidense Yo diría que finalmente
podría beneficiar a todo Norteamérica
hemos renovado nuestra cooperación
con estos aliados y socios más cercanos
ninguno es más cercano que México y
Canadá para asumir los mayores desafíos
que enfrenta la región francamente
también el mundo porque ya no puede
haber ninguna duda ninguna en el mundo
interconectado de hoy no podemos
encerrarnos en muros
respecto de problemas compartidos somos
más fuertes somos mejores cuando
trabajamos juntos los tres
Y juntos hemos logrado grandes progresos
desde nuestras últimas Cumbres desde la
lucha por el 19 el fortalecimiento de
nuestra capacidad de salud pública a
invertir y construir una fuerza laboral
en El Siglo 21
en el tope de nuestra agenda de hoy es
mantener a Norteamérica como
la región económica más resiliente y más
competente con el comité del mundo
[Música]
no solamente se trata de respaldar
trabajos de buena paga en todos nuestros
países sino en general un gran
crecimiento ahora Estamos trabajando en
el futuro para fortalecer nuestra
cooperación en cadenas de suministro y
minerales críticos para poder seguir
acelerando nuestros esfuerzos de
construir las tecnologías del mañana
aquí en Norteamérica
esta Cumbre también construye a partir
de la consulta continua y la cooperación
continua el uno con el otro asumir los
desafíos e impactar a todas a nuestras
naciones todo nuestro hemisferio
está viviendo unos niveles y presentes
de migración mucho mayores en cualquier
otro momento de la historia y
Norteamérica
la Cumbre que tuvimos en 2021 en
Washington lanzamos la idea de un
enfoque regional y amplio
para un problema regional la idea pasó a
la declaración de Los Ángeles sobre la
migración y sobre la protección
adoptada por 21 países en la Cumbre de
las Américas Hace seis meses y estamos
trabajando juntos Especialmente con
nuestros socios norteamericanos para
cumplir con nuestros compromisos bajo
esa declaración incluyeron
una política particular para expandir
el paso legal de migrantes de Nicaragua
Cuba y Haití y estamos que están
buscando una mejor vida aquí en los
Estados Unidos de América También
queremos agradecerle a usted señor
presidente por ponerse la altura y
recibir en México aquellos
que no seguían caminos legales que
establecimos
para evitar los pasos ilegales a
nuestros países
en mi camino acá me detuve en El Paso
Texas para ver la situación con mis
propios ojos y para encontrarme con los
funcionarios de la de la patrulla
fronteriza esto ha puesto en
dificultades A las comunidades mexicanas
y estadounidenses en la frontera estamos
trabajando juntos para enfrentarnos a
este desafío de una manera que sostenga
nuestras leyes y proteja los derechos
humanos de los migrantes que están
enfrentando circunstancias desesperadas
También estamos trabajando juntos para
asumir
para enfrentar esta carga del tráfico
ilegal de personas y de drogas en los
últimos seis meses nuestras patrullas
conjuntas en México al resultado en el
arresto de más de siete mil siete mil
traficantes de personas capturamos más
de 200.000 libras de fentanilo una
sustancia mortal en la frontera y hoy
discutimos los tres cómo continuar
fortalecer y como profundizar esta lucha
para acabar con el flujo ilegal de
fentanil incluso enfrentando los
precursores que se utilizan en estas
drogas sintéticas
mientras vamos persiguiendo los
laboratorios donde se hacen y los las
Bodegas donde están alojadas también
Hablamos de enfrentar los compromisos
para hacer que Norteamérica
sea una una fuerza energética limpia y
creo que está al alcance nuestro y un
líder Global en enfrentar la crisis
climática eso significa que debemos
trabajar juntos para llegar a obtener
vehículos con cero emisiones las
estaciones de carga para vehículos
eléctricos que sean compatibles
en todas nuestras fronteras
internacionales significa explorar y
compartir mercados y Buscar el hidrógeno
limpio significa trabajar juntos para
cumplir con nuestros compromisos
ambiciosos sobre el acuerdo de París
incluyendo enfrentar
las emisiones de metano y de carbono
negro finalmente
como tres democracias vibrantes
reconocemos que nuestra mayor fortaleza
en nuestro pueblo y quiero decirlo de
nuevo
como las democracias que somos nuestra
mayor fortaleza son nuestro es nuestro
pueblo la fuerza de nuestro pueblo
la clave para nuestra ventaja
competitivo en el mundo es nuestra gran
diversidad entonces juntos
estamos trabajando para enfrentar las
inequidades
que han jugado un rol demasiado
importante al marginalizar comunidades
en ambos países queremos asegurarnos de
Que todos tengan una oportunidad justa
es una de las inversiones más
inteligentes que podemos hacer para
nuestro futuro y vamos a hacerla juntos
señor presidente señor Primer Ministro
me honra estar con ustedes hoy estoy
agradecido por tenerlos como socios y
debo agregar amigos mientras trabajamos
juntos
en realizar una visión compartida para
Norteamérica Muchas gracias